plus de 6 millions de sapins de noël
naturels ou artificiels sont vendus
chaque année en france
dans l'ancien temps on appelait la de
besné mais crosby les persistantes et le
sapin de noël est encore aujourd'hui une
tradition qui persistent chaque année le
roi des forêts prend possession des
salons et revêt ses habits de lumière
pour le plus grand plaisir des petits et
des grands
ça représente coin sapin dans une maison
la beauté à sa pa ti pa joies et les
cadeaux c'est en alsace dès le douzième
siècle que la coutume du sapin à part et
dans la tradition chrétienne
l'arbre de noël ne doit pas être érigés
avant le 24 décembre et doit être enlevé
12 nuits après pour l'épiphanie
mais les habitudes sont aujourd'hui bien
différente
43% des ménages français déclarent
acheter leur sa part entre le 1er et le
9 décembre
ils sont plus de 22 % à préférer lâcheté
entre le 10 et le 14 décembre et 30%
encore une semaine après et pour le
choix du sapin chacun ses exigences
c'est un synthétique que l'on met chaque
année on voulait que sa peine soit
suffisamment fourni il soit parce que
l'éthique assez grand on perd pas des
pires hier à ça parce que ça ça compte
en matière de résistance la réputation
des nordmann n'est plus à shell en 2000
seuls 29% des français le choisissez
contre 75 % en 2007
l'épicéa pourtant plus parfumée est
inverse de plus en plus délaissée mais
pour cet alsacien denis épicéa ni normal
son choix se portait sur une autre
variété de sapins ou à châteaulin
plastique parce que pour moi c'est mieux
parce que alors on enlève quelqu'un de
sympa dans la forêt tout ça c'est pour
ça tu es aussi les simples de survivre
certes plus cher à l'achat qu'un sa part
naturelle l'artificiel et pourtant
aujourd'hui plébiscité par 15% des
foyers français
mais sachez que quel que soit le sapin
que vous choisirez seul contrat votre
créativité
au moment de le décorer
[Musique]